صور خاصه ومن هنا اسامه اذا تنطلق عمليات
الاجلاء في معظمها
وطبعا هذا الميناء ميناء بورسودان قريب
جدا من ميناء جده في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
[موسيقى]
قد يكون اقرب الموانئ ربما خارج المملكه
طبعا يعني
نعم يعني اقرب الموانئ طبعا هو عثمان هو
اقرب الموانئ ميناء بورسودان نعلم انه
اقرب الموانئ بالنسبه
للسودان طبعا منه يتم عبر جده العبور الى
عدد كبير من من الدول
اليوم صباحا او امس قامت يعني
اللجنه المشتركه الفريق المشترك لعمليه
الاله هنا في مدينه باب السودان بالاشراف
على عمليه اجراء
لاكثر من
1200 شخص يحملون جنسيات عربيه واوروبيه تم
اجلائهم واكتمال سفرهم قبل ان ترسوا قبل
ان تتحرك بهم السفينه التجاريه بحسب مصادر
انها مستاجره من السعوديه قام على يعني
الركض كان علمتنها
400 شخص يحملون جنسيات مختلفه منها عربيه
ومنها اوروبيه وبينهم دبلوماسيون
دبلوماسيون كذلك تحرك تحركت هذه السفينه
الى ميناء جده طبعا ثم بعد ذلك بجده طبعا
في هذه الحاله تكون معبر لعدد من الدول
الاخرى خاصه في حاله الاغلاق الكامل الذي
يعني يحيط ببعض الحدود السودانيه هناك بعض
الحدود البريه هي ايضا معبر الذين يطلبون
المغادره على سبيل الاخلاء اليوم يعني
ايضا ما تحدثنا عن مطار باور سودان الدولي
وليس ليس هنا فقط في ميناء بورسودان حيث
تتم وهي طبعا المطار هو واحده من الوسائل
المتبعه في عمليه الاجلاء خلال الاربعه
ايام الماضيه هنا في مدينه بورسودان اليوم
خلال ساعات الماضيه تحركت اقلع الطائره
جزائريه طائره عسكريه جزائريه وعلمتها
عشرات الرعايه الجزائريين الى الجزائر
هناك ايضا طائره يعني
يتم اكتمال الاجراءات
للمسافرين على متنها خلال في هذه اللحظات
وهي طائره هنديه ايضا على متنها اكثر من
ثلاثه اكثر من 300 شخص ايضا عدد من
الطائرات الاخرى ربما تاتي تباعا خلال
الساعات القليله القادمه اغلب هذه
الطائرات كما علمنا انها طائرات عسكريه
يعني تقوم بعمليه الهبوط ثم بعد ذلك تكتمل
الاجراءات بالنسبه للمسافرين الذين يصلون
الى مطار طور سودان الدولي وكذلك
المسافرين عبر البحر هنا تتم استضافتهم
بعد وصولهم الى المدينه والاشراف على يعني
الاجراءات المتعلقه بوجودهم في هذه
المدينه ثم بعد ذلك تكتمل الاجراءات سفرهم
ويصعد الى علامات السفن ثم تتحرك هذه
السفن يعني اذا هذه السفن طبعا بطبيعه
الحال
الان هذه هي مثلا هذه السفينه الحربيه
الفرنسيه
نشاهد طبعا على متنها تحمل طائره مروحيه
عسكريه بكامله تجهيزاتها العسكريه ونشاهد
كذلك الجنود على متن هذه القطعه الحربيه
الفرنسيه
المكتمله التسليح او عدد ايضا اخر نتوقع
ان يصل اتباعا خلال
الساعات القليله القادمه للمشاركه في
اجلاع عمليه اجلاء مستمره تواجهها السلطات
السودانيه هنا وتقول انها يعني بالنسبه
لها تمثل تحديا كبيرا بالنسبه لها في ظل
الظروف الامنيه المعقده منذ بدايتها وحتى
نهايتها ولكن قالت انها تعتزم ان تكون هذه
الاجراءات سلسه وان تكون امنه حتى ايصال
كل الذين يريدون ايلائهم خلال
الازمه القائمه في السودان هذه
بطبيعه الحال ان نحن نتحدث كما ذكرنا بعمل
عن حول عمليه عمليه اجلاء مستمره بالظروف
الامنيه يعني
الظروف الامنيه المعقده الجميع يحاول
الاجلاء رعاياها عبر
الطيران العسكري او البوارج الحربيه او
المدنيه التي تاتي الى بورتسودان ولكن يظل
تحديا مهما تامين الطريق يعني كيف يصل
هؤلاء الى الى بورسودان في المقام
الاول هذا يمثل ربما التحدي الاكبر
كما ذكرنا الظروف المحيطه بعمليه الاجلاء
ليست ظروف طبيعيه عثمان يعني منذ بدايه
الرحله علامتنا الحافلات والبصات النقل
الجماعي من مدينه الخرطوم وعدد من المدن
السودانيه الاخرى تتحرك هذه البصات تقوم
بتامينها كما ذكر الجيش السوداني يعني
قوات سودانيه حتى اكتمال وصولها الى مدينه
بورسودان وهذا هو التحدي الاكبر خاصه في
ظل الظروف الامنيه المعقده ليس في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم او في مناطق متفرقه من
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم ولكن حتى في
الشوارع يعني الشوارع طبعا ايضا وهي هي
الاخرى تعاني من سيوله امنيه فيها كثير من
الحوادث التي ترتبط بعمليات السلب والنهب
يعني حدثت عده حوادث في
اثناء سفر بعض الوفود سوى كانت
الدبلوماسيه منها منها او حتى في حركه
المواطنين يعني هناك عدد من المواطنين
تعرضوا لعمليات السلب والنهب وسرقت ونهبت
سياراتهم تحت تهديد السلاح كذلك يعني نهبت
اموالهم وهي اموال طائله كما تحدثنا مع
بعض الذين تعرضوا لهذه
الحوادث كذلك يعني حتى لم تسلم لم يسلم
الوقود لبعض السيارات فمن يسيطر هل هناك
تنتشر في هناك نعم هل هناك طريق رئيسي
معين يربط
بورسودان بالخرطوم وبالتالي هل توجد جهه
تسيطر على هذا الطريق ام لا الجيش على
سبيل المثال او قوات الدعم السريع
وبالتالي تكون مسؤوله عن تامين كل من يمر
بهذا الطريق وان لا يتعرضوا لعمليات نهبه
او سلب
كما ذكرت لك عثمان يعني قياده المنطقه
العسكريه هنا للبحر الاحمر قالت انها تقوم
بتتصدى لعمليه الحمايه الكامله لضمان
سلامه كل المسافرين الذين يتم باجلائهم عن
طريق البحر او عن طريق مطار السودان
الدولي طبعا من الخرطوم يسلكون الطريق
القومي الرابط بين الخرطوم القضارف كسلا
وصولا الى مدينه بورسودان هذا الطريق طريق
طويل بطبيعه الحال يعني يصل طوله لنحو الف
كيلو متر الف كيلو متر ولذلك كلما طال
الطريق طبعا تزداد ربما الخطوره في حاله
وجود سيوله امنيه في بعض المناطق وفي بعض
النقاط لذلك الجيش يقول انه يقوم بعمليه
عمليه الحمايه الكامله وبالتالي نحن نفهم
من هذا الكلام ان السيطره الكامله في عام
لهذا الطريق طالما ان الجيش قال انه يقوم
بالحمايه الكامله
وتوفير السلامه
للذين يتيم اجلائهم عبر البصات باصات
النقل الجماعي والحافلات الى مدينه
بورسودان نفهم من ذلك انه يسيطر على هذا
الشارع ليس هذا شارع فقط وانما اي طريق
يتم عن طريقه اجلاء الذين يتم يعني الذين
المسافرين الذين يتم اجلائهم من الخرطوم
وعدد من المدن السودانيه الاخرى عمليه
الاله لا تتم فقط من العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم وانما يعني اعداد من يعني كنا
نتحدث صباح اليوم عن عمليه الاجلاء
للرعايه هنود يعني الرعايه الهنود تحركوا
من الخرطوم بعضهم بعضهم تحرك من مدينه
كسلا كسلا فيها واحده من اكبر الجاليات
الهنديه في السودان وكذلك بعض المدن
السودانيه الاخرى
يعني عمليه التامين هذه عمليه ربما شاقه
ومعقده خاصه في ظل استمرار المواجهات وفي
ظل استمرار تمركز القوات السودانيه في عدد
من المناطق التي تقوم بتامينها وكذلك هذه
ربما يتم عمليه الحمايه هذه ربما تتم على
حساب مهمات الجنود في الميدان المهمات
القتاليه في الميدان
مساله الحرب والمواجهه المسلحه يعني اسامه
عندما تقول اكبر رجاليه هنديه موجوده في
كسلا ربما ربما نشير الى ان هؤلاء الهنود
منهم من هو في السودان منذ عشرات السنين
وهو عمليا هم عمليا سودانيون ويتحدثون
باللهجه السودانيه بطلاقه ربما لم يتوقعوا
ابدا ان ياتي يوما مثل هذا يضطرون فيه الى
مغادره السودان
طبعا الجاليه السودانيه في السودان واحده
من اقدم واعرق الجاليه الهنديه الاجنبيه
حتى ان الثقافه حتى ان الثقافه السودانيه
الجائله الهنديه نعم واحده من اكبر
الجاليات في السودان
تجربوا الثقافات السودانيه اصبحوا يتحدثون
اللغه اللهجه السودانيه بطلاقه
واصبحوا جزءا من المجتمعات المحليه يعني
هناك تواصل اجتماعي كثيف ما بين المجتمعات
المحليه وهذه والجاليه الهنديه على سبيل
اسامه يعني سوف نعود اليك في وقت لاحق
ربما في النشره المقبله
ونحاول ان نفهم اكثر عن هذه النقطه سواء
الجاليه الهنديه او الجاليات الاخرى شكرا
لك اسامه السيد احمد في بورتس